as a working mom thoughts on studies on
negative effects of Early Child Care no
hate okay this is a great question there
are a lot of studies on early daycare
having negative outcomes for your kid in
pretty nasty ways so uh I'll tell you
guys what I'm doing and then I can tell
you my opinions but what I'm doing is
I'm getting a newborn care specialist uh
for for night times so I'll be
breastfeeding at night anyway but I'll
have somebody there who can kind of
bring me the baby I'll breastfeed and
then they can take the baby back calm
them down put them back to sleep I've
got such a difficult time I have such a
difficult time getting to sleep that if
I didn't have help in that way I
wouldn't sleep and if I didn't sleep
like that I wouldn't be able to continue
with all these projects that I'm doing
that I want to continue with so I really
need to to focus on getting as much
sleep as I can so we have a newborn care
specialist helping and I'm going to have
a nanny as well so that's two people
helping me and thank God I can afford
that at this point because with Scarlet
I didn't have anybody
and it was really hard I started
working pretty quickly after I had
Scarlet but when she was 6 months I was
full-time working but I had like the
baby on me at home and I was working um
so I never did
daycare and part of the reason for that
was
because I was fortunate enough to be
able to afford help so with Scarlet I
got a
nanny um when she was 11 months old and
I was still working from home so I was
still able to breastfeed but it was
somebody there that could watch her
while I was
working
and that's what I I could barely afford
that like that took almost all my money
but uh that
I think that that if that's something
you can do I think that that's a better
idea than doing daycare when kids are
really young
uh let me
think that's my opinion and then there's
also a realm of daycares you can look
into like sometimes daycare is your
neighbor who brings over three or four
kids and then she's taking care of three
or four kids in this really homey
environment that's different than then
like 14 kids to daycare resentful
daycare workers that don't care about
your kids and I think that's where
things get iffy and then I would say if
you are going to put your kids in
daycare you can also judge how it's
going like are you dropping off your kid
and they're
screaming like screaming and are they
screaming and it's been two weeks and
they're still screaming when you drop
them off probably that's not a great
sign right now maybe they're three and a
half and you have them in daycare and
they're just going Bye Mom see you later
I don't think those are the kids that
end up with problems so is as a parent
you need
to judge that and be aware of that and
try to set up something that doesn't
traumatize your kids that's important so
for me I felt like that was getting
extra help while I was at home and I was
like I said fortunate enough that I
barely could afford that but I could was
scarlet and now I can afford more help
thank goodness
so I think you have to be aware of the
negative effects of daycare on kids
and make sure you don't traumatize your
kid right and I do think that the excuse
of like well well that's what I can
afford like I need
to drop them off at this cheaper daycare
where there's 14 kids when they're 8
months
old maybe figure out something else
cuz you don't want your kid having traa
forever so maybe don't do that it's like
figure out something else and I really
don't believe that people in general
don't have options like you do have
options you're just not willing to
pursue those options I also don't think
that you should feel guilty though about
getting help and I felt really bad even
when Scarlet was 11 months old and I got
a nanny she was either 10 months or 11
months old and I got a nanny and I felt
bad getting a nanny uh because my mom
was a stay-at-home mom and didn't have
help
and I thought that made me a bad mom and
I don't think that anymore at all I
think that you need to do whatever puts
you in a place where you're not
resentful and you're taking care of
yourself so that you can take care of
your kid cuz a resentful parent
especially a resentful parent towards
their child is one of the most toxic
things that can happen to a kid
so really try and plan out your life and
figure out how to make this possible for
you and it shouldn't be something that
breaks down your relationship or
traumatizes your
kid
there apologies if that wasn't as smooth
as it should have been I'm I have no
internal dialogue because my baby ate my
brain
[Music]
a